[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
geld davon haben sie gehört geld regiert
die welt doch was wenn sich das wesen
dieses geldes fundamental verändert wenn
es zum beispiel nicht in geldscheinen
sondern allein in form verschlüsselter
daten zirkuliert wenn es nicht mehr von
zentralbanken gesichert und geschöpft
wird sondern dezentral von allen
gemeinsam verwaltet und in seiner menge
absolut begrenzt ist wie etwa im falle
der mittlerweile global etablierten
crypto währung bitcoin welche folgen
hätte oder hat dieses neue geld für
unsere gesellschaften von nationen wie
die schweiz für die politische ordnung
auf unserem planeten
das diskutiere ich heute mit roscheba
beruf informatiker und professor an der
eth zürich und seit jahrzehnten mit den
technologien hinter crypto währungen wie
bitcoin beschäftigt sowie mit ijoma
mangold
literaturkritiker philosoph für thun ist
bei der wochenzeitung die zeit und der
art vom phänomen bitcoin fasziniert dass
selbst zurzeit an einem buch zu diesem
thema sitzt schön sind sie beide da
erwarten hofer sie forschen seit sehr
langer zeit haben auch ein buch zu den
technologien hinter bitcoin geschrieben
insbesondere der block chain technologie
nun gibt es aus ihrem munde ein zitat
das uns alle meine ich aufhorchen lassen
sollte ich lese es mal vor es handelt
sich bei der block 10 um eine der
aufsehenerregendsten
wissenschaftlichen entwicklungen der
letzten 100 jahre
und diese wird so fahren sie fort unsere
gesamte gesellschaft
unsere gesamte gesellschaft fundamental
verändern das stammt aus dem jahre 2018
ich nehme an das hat sich nicht geändert
ihre einschätzung das hat sich nicht
geändert ich würde ein bisschen
präzisieren dass ich frauen die
kryptographie als wirklich interessantes
phänomen betrachtet als verschlüsselungs
verschlüsselungstechnik aus fundament
von der blog zu blog janis dann mehr die
anwendung von der kündiger will und wie
sie gesagt haben es kann starke
änderungen geben beim gilt die rolle der
zentralbanken aber wahrscheinlich auch
darüber hinaus bei der rolle von
materialen bei der rolle vom staat die
rolle von der demokratie wenn man die
demokratie wald solche dinge würde ich
erwarten dass die jungs beschäftigen
werden in der nächsten zeit lässt sich
diese veränderungen in ihrer dimension
vielleicht sogar mit der
entwicklung und der etablierung des
internets vergleichen also gibt es
gleich noch eine digitale revolution
nach der revolution die mit dieser
technologie verbunden ist das buch habe
ich damals geschrieben war wie jemand
genau das gesagt hat dass die blogger
noch viel größer als das internet das
glaube ich persönlich nicht ich glaube
das ist eigentlich wichtig sein wird das
anwendung des internets die gewisse
andere wichtigen unternehmen des
internets aber das internet ist das
fundament von all diesen sachen und dem
sind ist das vielleicht die wichtige
entwicklung herr mangold die potenziale
sind groß das geheimnis ist dass auch
sie sind von hause literaturkritiker
gegenwarts beobachter können sie denn
sagen wann sie zum ersten mal als
mutmaßlich außenstehender von dem
phänomen bitcoin und block chain gehört
haben und was wie man das heute so sagt
das mit ihnen gemacht hat ja tatsächlich
bin ich ja selber von mir überrascht
dass ich als ästhet der sich ganz mit
mit keine ahnung maße brust und goethe
beschäftigt plötzlich fasziniert von
technologie ich bin wirklich nicht dafür
prädestiniert aber tatsächlich hat es
nicht gepackt und typisches phänomen es
war natürlich ein pandemie phänomen als
wenn nämlich zum ersten mal
zurückgezogen zeit hatten uns so deep
dive mäßig auf irgendeinen neuen
gegenstand wirklich einzulassen und ich
weiß ist es nicht lange her als ich
feuer gefangen habe aber dann war es
auch um mich geschehen ist war januar
2021 als sie anfing darüber nachzudenken
was meint eigentlich bitcoin das ist
eine digital erzeugte knappheit das fand
ich es auch wirklich aus der
philosophischen perspektive so
erstaunlich ich dachte bisher
knappheit sei etwas quasi eine reale in
der welt ja wie gold wir wissen zwar
nicht genau wie viel gold es gibt aber
wir wissen es halt eine begrenzte menge
von übrigen von bitcoin gibt es mit
digitalen möglichkeiten auch nur eine
absolut begrenzte menge und das ist
etwas was wir von digitalen sphäre nicht
zu denken gewohnt sind genau dass man
das nämlich erzeugen kann das ist das
faszinierende und deswegen würde ich
tatsächlich auch noch etwas radikaler
als sie einschätzen was die erfindung
von bitcoin oder von crypto währung auf
der blog stellen bedeutet denn
tatsächlich ist glaube ich nicht nur
eine anwendung des internets sondern ich
würde sagen während internet eine
kopiermaschine war das heißt man konnte
im internet jeder weise sie verschicken
foto per mail dann hat der empfänger das
foto sie haben es aber auch dass das
internet kopiert alles deswegen war es
bisher für den transfer von werten von
value nicht geeignet weil das führt zur
verdopplung wenn ich quasi per e-mail
ihn geld schicke haben sie es und ich
denn es wird nur kopierers für geld
besonders problematisch sehr
problematisch ist und die generalität
des konzerts des bitkom protokolls
besteht darin plötzlich diese begrenzung
herbeiführen zu können dass man dass das
problem man nennt das immer das problem
des double spending
ausgeschlossen wird und damit wird
plötzlich das internet zum ersten mal
fähig werte zu transferieren und wenn
man sich jetzt überlegt im nächsten
schritt das quasi jede soziale aktion in
dieser welt fast jede soziale aktion mal
abgesehen von den liebeserklärung an die
nächsten auch immer ein zahlungsart ist
auch immer mit geld verbunden ist dann
wird man glaube ich die dimension dieser
fundamentalen revolution klar also sie
würden sagen es verändert die art und
weise wie wir als menschen interagieren
ist sofern der wert austauschen was wir
fast immer tun ob wir es eingestehen
oder nicht jetzt merken wir da ist
unfassbar viel energie schöne energie
enthusiasmus drin und es gibt ja so ein
ein narrativ das sagt den meist menschen
ich weiß nicht ob es ihnen auch so geht
aus erfahrung zuerst ist skepsis dann
ist staunen dann ist faszination und
dann geht man in diesem thema verloren
ist das in etwa auch ihre erfahrung mit
diesem thema bei mir war es komplett
umgekehrt weil also dass zuerst mal
gesehen habe bitcoin das ist schon sehr
lange her
da war ich überrascht wie schlecht das
gemacht ist es ist dem vorstand zusammen
dann auch so gegangen das gedacht haben
die person die das gemacht hat die hat
sich nicht wirklich gut ausgekannt mit
der forschung er hat viele sachen
ignoriert die wir schon seit vielen
jahrzehnten mussten
und dass man ganz anders gemacht auf
eine clevere art sachen zusammengebaut
haben mittel ähnlich wie das iphone und
das war doch zu einer ähnlichen zeit da
wurden fliegen die technologien
zusammengebaut aber wenn man jetzt ein
wissenschaftler gefragt hat der wir das
zusammen bad hätte wahrscheinlich ganz
anders zusammen gebracht also ich war
erschrocken hat jedoch da digitale
wertungs support aber warum machen die
das so und so und so geht's gut ich darf
ich da kurz ein haken weil ich glaube
das faszinierende warum auch so viele
unterschiedliche menschen sich
begeistern können für den bitkom ist das
da verschiedene wissensbereiche
zusammengekommen einerseits die
kryptographie da sind sie der fachmann
die das wissen von vernetzten von
vernetzten kommt
datenspeichern aber eben auch etwas
geldpolitisches hat etwas ökonomisches
und die generalität von sagen wir diesen
namen zum ersten mal in dieser sendung
sendung mit angemessener feierlichkeit
von satori nakamoto ein pseudonym wir
wissen nicht wer dahinter steckt und
dass ein mann eine frau oder ein
kollektiv ist jedenfalls diese figur
satori nakamoto die 2008 das berühmte
whitepaper das bitcoin entwickelt hat
hat es übrigens hier und es trägt den
durchaus protagen titel bitcoin
peer-to-peer electronic cash system ein
peer-to-peer elektronisches
zahlungssystem und das sind acht seiten
von denen man doch sagen kann sie haben
unsere welt wie wir sie kennen bereits
verändert genau die generalität von
satori nakamoto besteht eben darin diese
drei verschiedenen bereiche zusammen zu
führen und dann würde ich sagen nein
darin ist der bitkom absolut genial denn
er reagiert auch auf eine konkrete
politische oder währungspolitische
situation in dem ersten block in satori
nakamoto gemeint gemeint hat aber man
kann in so einem blog nicht nur die
entscheidenden hash werte eingeben
sondern quasi wie so ein paar mangold
wir sind schon ganz tief drin in diesem
können lassen und sprache dekoren
reagiert auf die finanzkrise das ist so
entscheidend zu wissen der bitkom
reagiert auf die finanzkrise auf die
tatsache dass die zentralbanken mal
wieder nicht zum ersten mal mal wieder
wall street haus gebraucht der bailout
der banken betrieben haben und da sagt
sakamoto wir brauchen ein geld das
unabhängig ist das nicht manipulierbar
ist das für jeden zugänglich ist wir
haben eine riesige menge auf dieser welt
von sogenannten bengt leuten also leute
kein konto in diesem sinne gar nicht an
wirtschaftssystem teilnehmen für alle
die hat denn diesen bitcoin erfunden und
in dieser perspektive finden ich
arbeitete er erstaunlich wahnsinnig gut
ganz ganz interessant wir müssen
vielleicht kurz erklären es gibt eine
art schöpfungsmythos der mehr ist als
ein mythos eine reale geschichte im
jahre 2008 zum höhepunkt der finanzkrise
erscheint dieses paper von einer person
die sich sarkozy nakamoto nennt von
deren identität bis heute nichts genaues
bekannt ist und dort wird eine neue form
elektronischen geldes vorgeschlagen und
heute etwa
14 jahre später werden dort wöchentlich
billionen von dollar durch dieses
netzwerk
transferiert weitgehend fehlerfrei wie
man meint höchst sicher und ohne größere
probleme was mich jetzt auf eine
initiale frage bringt bevor wir
versuchen genauer zu verstehen was da
passiert mit der block c sie haben nun
gesagt da waren wahnsinnig viele
probleme drin während es andere leute
sondern gibt die sagen es ist fast
unglaublich fast übermenschlich dass
jemand dieses problem auf diese art aus
dem stand in einer solchen perfektion
gelöst hat was denn nun kommt vielleicht
davon mich wohl wisse man dass man hat
ich kenne durchaus leute die betrachten
dieses whitepaper auf people aus
offenbarung
für die menschheit
ich sehe einfach dass wir früher
natürlich in den achtzigern den
neunziger jahren schon über die gitarre
währungen gesprochen haben auch damals
musste man diese probleme schon lösen
und ich würde sagen nach dem motto hat
diese ideen die es gab einfach
zusammengepackt und ja ein ganzes
verpackt zum beispiel die idee von proof
of work sprechen wir darüber noch die
wurde bei e mail das erste mal
vorgeschlagen was man sagte man kann das
e mail spam problem zu lösen dass jedes
mal wenn ich eine e-mail versendet muss
ich ein klein bisschen arbeit machen und
klein bisschen rechnen und dann kann ich
nicht millionen von e mails schicken
sondern nur noch wenige war das kostet
mich ein bisschen ordnung und all diese
kleinen dinge die da drin sind wurden
zwar einen schönen ganzen zusammen
dessen kann man das so beschreiben es
gibt ja innovationen die aus dem quasi
nichts etwas ganz neues etablieren dann
gibt es innovationen die sind
synthetische art da gibt es in einem
feld verschiedene länder und die werden
dann
zusammengeknotet und die würden sagen
bitcoin ist solch eine art von
innovation ist es aber das iphone ist
auch solche ich glaube wahrscheinlich
wenn man drin ist dann ist fast wie man
auf so eine art von innovation
vielleicht im künstlerischen bereich
oder sogar schon ist man ganz radikal
anderes macht aber in der technologie
ist das oft so dass wir wirklich sachen
geschickt neu konstruieren zusammen
bauen wollte manchmal reicht verändern
verbessern ich stimme herrn attenhofer
vollkommen zu vertuschen nakamoto aus
unterschieden bereichen greift er
bereits entwickelte gedanken auf und
fügt sie zu einem neuen konzept zusammen
ich finde das deswegen aber auch
besonders wichtig zu betonen weil man
dann historisch versteht woher das kommt
es kommt nehmen wir aus dem umfeld der
cyberpunk bewegung der späten 80er
frühen 90er jahre eine bewegung die die
wir gar nicht hoch genug und können für
ihre früher hell sich das heißt in den
90er jahren oder so alte boomer wie ich
noch nicht mal eine e mailadresse hatten
haben die in ihrem berühmten cyberpunk
manifest bereits vor allem gewarnt was
wir heute haben also stichwort big data
also dass die
durchsichtigkeit und die privacy
aufgelöst wird und von großen konzernen
und so daten gespeichert werden und die
wahren libertäre anarchisten die wolken
keine kontrolle weder kontrolle durch
den staat noch kontrolle durch große
über mächtige konzerne und dann sagten
sie zwei punkte müssen wir technologisch
realisieren um uns und freiheit zu
retten das eine ist wir brauchen ein
internet wo wir nicht identifizierbar
sind das ist das tor nicht geworden
katharina wagner genannte darknet und
das andere war sie sagten wenn alles
digital wird es sein die komplett voraus
fisch deutlicher voraus als alle anderen
menschen als wenn alles digital wird
dann ist auch vollkommen klar dass wir
auch finanztransaktionen machen müssen
wenn das ganze leben sich ins internet
verlage und dann müssen genau diese
finanztransaktion aber auch nicht
überprüft bei sein bzw nicht
bewilligungsfähig
so dass jeder der will die freiheit wie
man heute mit bargeld zahlen und seither
gab es diesen wunsch oder war klar das
ist was wir brauchen wir brauchen ein
digitales unabhängiges geld und daran
haben viele gearbeitet und das war noch
teilweise das waren vorläufer in den
ideen vor unser tor steinacker motor mit
etwas anderen lösungen die aber nie
wirklich praktikabel oder nie umgesetzt
worden sind und dann in den nuller
jahren hat man das projekt quasi
vergessen es kommt die finanzkrise und
plötzlich sehen wir sowohl der zentralen
instanz der zentralbanken nicht mehr
ausgeliefert sein und darf bietet der
bitcoin die antwort schon mal ganz
interessant für mich und auch für alle
die das jetzt hören es geht offenbar
nicht nur um geld sondern es geht um
mehr als geld versteht vielleicht daran
dass es bei geld immer um mehr geht als
um geld aber um ein bisschen ein gefühl
dafür zu gewinnen worum es da geht und
welche technologien war saal sind
schauen wir uns jetzt einen kleinen film
zur blog chain technologie an auf der
auch der bitcoin als innovation beruht
in einer blog chain werden daten in
blöcken aneinander gebunden und das
chronologisch jeder block erhält eine
art schloss das ihn an einen
unverrückbaren platz in der kette
schließt diese schloss ist der
sogenannte
caches bestehen aus öffentlichen und
privaten schlüsseln sie sind also so
etwas wie der verschlüsselten
fingerabdruck eines blogs der immer auf
den vorgänger passen muss ein einzelner
blog kann nicht gelöscht werden da sonst
die hashes nicht mehr passen denn ändert
sich an datenblock dann ändert sich
nämlich auch der hash und sie passen
nicht mehr zusammen
jede neue datenblock wird immer am ende
hinzugefügt es entsteht eine art
lückenloses fortlaufendes kassenbuch
dass man nicht unterbrechen und nicht
löschen kann
[Musik]
speziell ist weiterhin eine blog shane
ist ein verteiltes system das gesamte
kassenbuch wird auf vielen computern auf
sogenannten notes oder knoten innerhalb
des block c netzes verteilt und als
kopie gespeichert
kommt ein neuer blog hinzu muss auch
dieser in jeder kopie im netzwerk
akzeptiert werden
das macht eine blog jane sehr sicher es
ist sehr unwahrscheinlich dass jemand
all diese kopien hecken das heißt
manipulieren könnte
erwarten hofer ich habe jetzt drei
zentrale dinge mit gekommen dezentral
dann gibt es ein verschlüsselungs aspekt
der krypto logisch ist und dann gibt es
den aspekt dass da eine art von
buchhaltung betrieben wird da haben wir
es noch mal ganz einfach für so sehen
wie mich die sich damit nicht
beschäftigt haben anhand einer
spielzeugeisenbahn das ist also ein
erster blog jetzt entsteht eine
transaktion mit diesen mutmaßlichen wert
blog und das heißt da wird ein neuer
blog hinzugefügt und zwar anhand eines
schlüssel der
kryptographisch eine besondere
eigenschaft hat richtig es ist wichtig
dass der neue block kann nur an dann
muss man muss sagen momentan anfügt und
das muss genau passen es gibt so wir
sind wieder konjunktur und um das zu
verifizieren muss eine gewisse leistung
erbracht werden nicht um zu verifizieren
das ist eine sehr kleine leistung zu
geprüft und das der schlüssel stimmt das
kann man sehr schnell machen aber um den
block zu generieren das wurde einfach so
gebaut von nakamoto dass er oder sie
wollte dass das theater viel arbeit
dahinter steckt also an meinen das nicht
man meinen das ist so ähnlich wie lotto
spielen muss quasi im lotto gewinnen das
ist man kann sehr viel sehr viele
scheine kaufen und man kann überlegen
irgendwann ein schein trifft bei bitcoin
ist es so dass die wahrscheinlichkeit so
einen richtigen noten zu holen das ist
wie im richtigen lotto dreimal
hintereinander gleich hintereinander zu
gewinnen
aber sex richtig zu haben mit zusatz zu
haben also es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich
dass man so eine so viel glück gehabt
was die technologie sehr sicher macht
was diese technologie ich weiß nicht ob
sie sicher macht auch das ist einfach so
gebaut wurden hier nicht nötig glaube
ich das so zu bauen aber das ist dann
auch die pid könne das gemacht haben
dahinter steht eine spiel theoretische
überlegung nämlich die männer sollen
die historie des bitcoins glaubwürdig
oder wahrheitsgemäß abbilden und damit
die kein unfug touren verlangen wir von
ihnen dass sie erst mal hoch investieren
das heißt durch die rechenleistung die
sie einbringen die kostet ihnen geld das
machen sie nur wenn sie dafür die
aussicht haben eine reward eine
belohnung dafür zu bekommen der in
diesem fall wiederum darum darin besteht
bitcoins zur erhöhung wenn man kein
selbsttragendes und selbst generieren
das system in diesem sinne kriegt neue
bitcoins wenn man so einen blog findet
und das ist auch die der finanzielle
anreiz damit zu machen für die man
kriegt soundsoviel bitcoins also pro
stunde werden etwa eine million franken
aus bitcoins neu verteilt und
entsprechend viel energie geht in dieses
system weil dieser lottoscheine die kann
man mit energie quasi berichten jetzt
gibt es noch eine zweite eigenheit diese
block 10 wird ja immer länger weil die
transferierung geschichte immer länger
wird und es ist offenbar so dass nicht
nur wert transferiert wird so wie es zum
beispiel von einem konto auf das andere
steht sondern in der transferierung
selbst ist auch die validierung das
heißt die bestätigung dass dieser wert
wirklich wertvoll ist enthalten das
heißt es werden zwei dinge mit einer
technologie gelöst kann man das so sagen
einmal die transferierung und einerseits
die bestätigung dass es sich um gutes
werthaltiges material hand oder und
gutes geld in diesem fall ja was in
ihrem zug drin in jedem morgen drin hat
viele neue transaktionen drin die ich
hänge ja und damit bestätigt sozusagen
die historie davon wenn ich einen bart
und einer bestehenden zugkomposition
anhänge dann geht das wie weiter
bestätigt was vorher schon passiert ist
jetzt könnte passieren dass zwei leute
gleichzeitig versuchen einen wagen zu
hängen und das ist tatsächlich paket
können auch
möglich und häufig tv zumindest früher
häufig der fall
und dann muss man überlegen ja was ist
jetzt die wahrheit oder steht für die
wahrheit im linken angehängten wagen
einen rechten angehängten morgen die
bitcoin das löst ist dass es sagt ich
sage einfach welche kette länger wird
das ist ja wohl weitere wagen angehängt
werden und die längere kette ist die
wahrheit und die kürzere kette die
bricht er ab da hat niemand mehr
interesse weiterer anzuhängen und das
ist wie war hatte nie passiert ist und
warum entscheiden wir uns für die
längere kette weil sie mehr
rechenleistung eingegangen es das ist
das incentive das heißt es nach händels
approve erwerb und das ist auch die
informatik seite wirklich nicht leicht
zu knacken und zu verstehen es gibt eine
schöne analogie die auch wirklich passt
und die daher kommt ja auch die ganze
begrifflichkeit ist das gold mining auch
um gold zu aus der mine herauszuholen
bedarf es einer großen arbeits
anstrengung das reguliert quasi die
relative knappheit von gold also es
kostet etwas gold aus der erde zu holen
anders und das ist der große unterschied
zu den geld währungen die wir kennen im
bid cover wird ist dass fiat geld
genannt wird hat eine friert kann es aus
der bibel es werde gott sagt es werde
licht quasi mit knopfdruck wird das geld
geschaffen ohne dass der kosten
entstehen deswegen ist es beliebig
vermehrbar und beim gold oder bei allen
harten assets wenn man so möchte das
gold wie beim bitkom ist das nicht
möglich sondern es kostet etwas und das
heißt dieser hohe energieverbrauch der
dem bitkom oft zum vorwurf gemacht wird
ist nicht irgendwie so eine zufällige
unschöne hässliche begleiterscheinungen
sondern es eigentlich das herz dieser
währung und ihres funktionierens das ist
das was den bitkom hart macht es gibt
aber noch eine andere einheit bevor wir
auf diese härte das bitcoins eingehen
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe ist
der bitcoin mit geldscheinen denken
würde wie ein geldschein auf dem
sämtliche transaktionen die mit diesem
geld schein getätigt würden in gewisser
weise eingeschrieben sind also wenn ich
jetzt eine franken
schein bekomme dann ist das als ob ich
die ganze historie dessen was dieser
franke in seinem leben durchgemacht hat
mit auf diesen franken stehen hätte ist
das richtig also dass das physische gilt
ist ein bisschen eine schlechte
technologie wende ich persönlich immer
weil ich finde das konto system noch
eine bessere energie also wenn man eine
transaktion kriegt man kriegt man geld
auf sein konto zum geschrieben wenn man
wieder das geld ausgibt geht's auch ein
weiteres konto weiter aber in der jane
sieht man halt dann das geld wurde da
schließlich maurer erfunden und dann ist
es dahin gegangen dahin gegangen als in
der jane kann man das nachprüfen
und das ist das ein bisschen anders
physisches geld habe ich das dann
wirklich mehr wie conti auf die man
einfach sehen kann
weil ich finde ihren vergleich trotzdem
interessant nämlich unter dem anderen
aspekt der software schlechte publicity
bitcoin sorgt mich dass es gelb für
kriminelle sei und da würde ich sagen na
ja wenn ich einen verbrecher bin würde
ich aber lieber mit cash bezahlen lassen
weil es da in der tat keine
rückverfolgbarkeit geben werde beim
bitcoin sämtliche transaktionen
rekonstruierbar sind der ganze bitkom
ist transparent für jeden jeder kann
seit 2009 jede transaktion nachprüfen
und deswegen sind auch sehr viele fälle
werden jetzt gerade den letzten den hack
von 2016 bei der bitcoin exchange bitte
facts glaube ich heißt sie
mit phoenix bitfenix bitfenix der ist
jetzt von der vom fbi aufgeklärt worden
arm und die bitcoin sind sogar zu
zurückgeholt worden weil alle schritte
nachvollziehbar sind der bitcoin sagt
man ist soll genügen nicht anonym ich
bin wenn ich über ein privatkino das
können wir gerne noch mal erklären also
wenn ich im bitkom system teilnehmer bin
ich zwar nicht mit meinem namen dabei
aber den spezifisch adressen der
pazifische adresse und wenn man dann
diese adresse wenn es der polizei gegen
diese adresse zu verknüpfen mit der
person die dahintersteht und irgendwann
das geld dem bitkom vielleicht ein
normales geld umwandler um die
information zusammen und identifizieren
ein individuum jetzt gibt es das problem
oder vielleicht sogar die lösung des
problems der sicherheit hier scheint die
idee des dezentral netzwerkes
entscheidend zu sein es ist ja offenbar
so diese validierung der einzelnen
blöcke die wird nicht von einer zentrale
instanz vorgenommen sondern von allen
die an diesem system partizipieren erst
mal die frage wie viele sind es im
moment als computer gedacht so ein als
orte und warum wird es dadurch sicherer
genau genau weiß nicht wie viele dass es
dafür tatsächlich erforscht prinzip wie
viel das genau sind weil diese computer
verbinden sich alle nur zu wenig anderen
computern aber man riecht und das ist ja
vielleicht hunderttausend computer auf
der ganzen welt sind im prinzip alle
eine kopie dieser block schein haben das
ist nicht ganz anders als bei einem
bankkonto sonst oder das ist sie auch
digital ihr bankkonto und auch da geht
es durch mehrere computer die wissen wie
viel geld sie auf dem bankkonto haben
vor sich in denen von denen ausfällt
dass die anderen es noch wissen der
große unterschiede sind vielmehr
computer hier ist weltweit
und der größte unterschied ist dass
jeder mitmachen kann also er kann seinen
computer kann dieses bild vom programm
laufen lassen und dann ist er dabei bei
diesen rund 1000 computer und macht das
durch seine partizipation auch
tendenziell sich hat auch genau macht
das sicher eine mehr überprüft des
versorgers mit rechten dingen zugehen
das ist ja das eigentliche wunder diese
dezentralität heißt auch es gibt keine
privilegierte position in dem system das
etwas was wir nicht kennen was
menschheitsgeschichte ich neu ist wir
merken das auch wenn ich bei wenn ich
meine pin zu meinem bankkonto vergessen
kann ich bei der bank anrufen dann
schickte mir ein neues passwort
gewissermaßen rekonstruiert es gibt mir
eine neue pin weil es immer ein gibt er
dass er die macht über das ganze system
hat und jederzeit jemanden ausschließen
kann drangsalieren kann oder was auch
immer das alles gibt es das unterliegt
ob
das risiko gewissen beim bitkom das
alles gibt's beim bitcoin nicht wenn ich
da meine meine private keys die qualen
der privaten zugang also gerade ich
sogar vergessen gibt es keine instanz
keine telefonnummer keine adresse ich
kann mich ja niemanden dann war's das
ich bin also voll in der
selbstverantwortung und ich glaube das
ist auch dem bluetooth oder das was aus
dem bitcoin tatsächlich wie ich meine
eine große starke
gesellschaftspolitische jugendbewegung
geradezu macht dass freiheit neu
definiert ist wirklich ein großer
schritt nach vorne in der geschichte der
freiheit und zur freiheit das wissen wir
alle die wird auch immer abschreckend
warum naja weil sie uns nicht so viel
verantwortung zumutet und der bitcoin
ist unglaublich konkret nachvollziehbar
dieses zusammenhang zwischen freiheit
und verantwortung
jetzt ist es ja so und das ist ja eine
kulturelle frage solche zentrale
instanzen die auch oft institutionen
sind die haben ja eine schöne funktion
den gewehren sicherheit die gewähren
regel starrheit die haben auch
vielleicht reserven die andere nicht
hätten und man kann sagen beim roman so
ein allwissender erzähler der das
sichert das hat auch seine funktion da
weiß man nehme ich immer was passiert
was ist denn so furchtbar schön für sie
aus technischer oder politischer
perspektive an dieser
gesichtslosen verbreitung von
verantwortung
für mich ist interessant dass es
funktioniert weil
warum sollte man etwas vertrauen das ist
ein prinzip das gegenteil und vertrauen
normalerweise für vertrauen sagen ich
vertraue ihnen institution und weil die
gibt es schon lange und die leute treten
vertrauenswürdig auf und hier haben
diese gesichtslose masse die einem auch
dieses vertrauen jetzt bieten kann
vielleicht sogar näher als diese
zentralisierte version bekommen müsst
ihr nicht so funktionieren aber das war
wirklich ein hauptanliegen bisher
schöpfen dass man das wirklich dass
jeder mitmachen kann das ist beliebig
und konnte dazu stoßen weg gehen es gibt
keine kontrollinstanz mehr das hat noch
keiner versucht möglichst umzusetzen das
ist wirklich niemand mehr gibt der das
kontrolliert und das hat dann ja auch
stark emanzipiert zuge weil man
beispielsweise um ein bankkonto eröffnen
zu dürfen gewisse voraussetzungen
erfüllen muss während die teilnahme
voraussetzung an diesem wert netzwerk
eigentlich nur ein smartphone ist oder
sogar noch ein nokia von von früher dass
die rechenleistung drin wurde das heißt
viele menschen auf der ganzen welt
könnten zugang zu diesem wert
transferierung system bekommen den sie
jetzt nicht haben es sind sogar
milliarden menschen potenziell absolut
da müssen wir uns auch manchmal aus
unserer westlichen perspektive heraus
gegeben die wir natürlich in einer form
der finanziellen privilegiert leben weil
für uns ein bankkonto etwas
selbstverständliches ist und wenn wir
dann einem land angehören das zum swift
systemen gehört dann ist es uns auch in
der lage unsere unserer tochter nach
amerika die studiengebühren zu
überweisen das gilt aber für etwa zwei
milliarden menschen auf dieser welt
nicht die sind an bengt und für die ist
der zugang wie sie es gerade sagt über
ein nokia system symbian system sehr
viel leichter und sie sind auch gewinn
vermischen lässt sagt man immer ja eben
barrierefrei karriere ein absolut
barrierefreier zugang dass der eine
aspekt und der andere aspekt nicht
weniger wichtig wir haben mittlerweile
zwar auch
ziemliche inflationsraten in deutschland
fünf den usa mit 7 prozent der bitcoin
ist ein von der idee her also
langfristig deflationäres geld das heißt
er ist ein guter hatch eine gute
absicherung gegen inflationäre tendenzen
der hand aber kann er kurz erklärt dass
das geld das ich habe in seiner
kaufkraft über einen zeitraum an
kaufkraft verliert wenn man fünf prozent
inflation hat kann man sich von 100
franken dann nur noch den gegenwert von
95 franken kaufen und das heißt alle die
dies auf der bank haben und nicht
arbeiten lassen die verlieren geld denn
das spüren wir im moment auch in den usa
oder in deutschland oder in der eu sehr
stark aber es gibt natürlich länder die
noch viel stärkerer weise schlechten
eltern salvador türkei wir erleben die
türkei mit hyperinflation venezuela dass
simbabwe wir kennen es selber aus der
eigenen historischen erfahrung aus von
123 in der in der weimarer republik das
heißt aber all diese länder die heute
unter einem inflations regime leiden die
gehen natürlich alle in den bitcoin weil
sie wissen dass es ein stabiles ein
sicheres geld ist und eines das eben
nicht durch politik manipulierbar ist
erwarten hofer jetzt mal die frage man
hatte das gefühl das ist so eine
eierlegende wollmilchsau dieses bitcoin
das ist dezentral und sicher es ist
anonym und absolut vertrauensvoll es ist
im wert eher wachsend als fallend jetzt
gibt es doch da einige dunkle seiten es
gibt das dark knight es gibt die
geldwäsche das sind alles phänomene die
damit verbunden sind aber ist es denn
wirklich so sicher wie man sagt geradezu
unknackbar oder wo würden sie sagen da
gibt es wirkliche schwächen über die man
sprechen muss
von der kryptographie hier habe ich
weniger angst dann eher wieder von der
persönlichen seite
natürlich wenn man selbst dieses
bankkonto besitzt selbst aufsetzen kann
verwaltet dann ist man selber schuld
wenn sondern gestohlen wird und man muss
natürlich diesen schlüssel mit dem man
zum gefordert dieses bankkonto auch
selbst gemachten und das ist etwas was
vielleicht nicht jedem liegt und es gibt
diese bekannten fälle von auf dessen
assistenten von ihnen hat seine
besonders hart erwischt wenn ich das
kurz erzählen darf dass der hatte
bitcoin auf seinem computer nicht
ausreichend geschützt dagegen werk war
300 millionen franken wenn ich es
richtig sehe man wusste dass wohl in der
szene und hat diesen computer attackiert
die bitcoin weggezogen und das geld war
perdu genau die haben dieses diesen
schlüssel gefunden auf dem computer und
haben dann eine transaktion gemacht wie
es auch heute machen können neben den
schlüssel hat kann man das geld weg
transferieren genau das haben sie
gemacht
und das geld war weg damals war es nicht
so viel wert ist der heutige wert damals
was er ja vielleicht hunderttausend
franken
erst bei dr das war mein erster
doktorand auf diesem thema es war
vielleicht sogar der erste land weltweit
aus diesem thema damals haben wir das
gesehen und gedacht das könnte spannend
sein ich war nicht einmal super
überzeugt am anfang auch das wirklich
ein thema wird für die zukunft dass wir
das gezeigt hat weil er war einer der
ersten bitcoin meiner aber es hat sich
sehr gelohnt davonzutragen aber man muss
dann bei allem respekt vor ihren
doktoranden auch sagen er hat sich auch
leichtsinnig verhalten denn das ist
natürlich was jedem neuen bitcoin gesagt
wird die verwahrung darf
selbstverständlich nicht auf dem
computer passieren denn wenn der gehackt
wird ist man ausgeliefert aber es gibt
so genannte quotes da ist man gegen
diese form des angriffs gefahr aber für
jetzt den normalverbraucher stellt
dieser zwang der selbst verwahrung unter
höchsten sicherheitsanforderungen doch
eine sehr hohe hürde da im eintritt in
das system absolut ich kann das so
bleibt bei mir selber erlebt sie kaufen
bitcoins so genannte exchange ist eine
börse für crypto währungen und da läuft
bis zu dem punkt läuft alles so wie sie
es aus dem konventionellen finanzsystem
gewohnt gewohnt sind zu überweisen an
diese exchange ihr fiat geld wenn es
angekommen ist ordnen sie die bitcoins
und dann werden die ihnen auf diese
exchange gut geschrieben und sie haben
ein passwort um dahin zu kommen wie beim
normalen controller mein konto wenn das
passwort vergessen ruft melden sie sich
bei den exchange kriegen neues passwort
es ist allerdings so dass ihre bitcoins
solange sie bei der exchange liegen
nicht wirklich zumindest im echten sinne
der bitcoin ideologie nicht wirklich
ihre bitcoins sind sie verfügen nicht in
eigenständiger weise darüber das tun sie
erst wenn sie diese bitcoins von der
exchange runterziehen eben auf ein
sogenanntes cold wolle das ist einfach
wie ein usb-stick da hatte jemand
rausziehen hat man die auch weg von
computern hat man direkt vom computer
und damit ist man auch gesichert falls
die exchange je gehackt wird kann nichts
passieren wenn man ist die bitcoins sind
jetzt in der eigenen verantwortung
diesen schritt zu machen der
technologisch nicht so wahnsinnig
schwierig ist aber psychologisch ein
wirklich herausfordert und ein ganzes
jahr ich überweise jetzt immer so kleine
auch teile wenige satow schießt weil ich
angst habe ich einen fehler mache und
schicke dir eine falsche adresse beide
lernen direkt usw ich würde sagen obwohl
ich so begeistert von bitkom rede habe
auch ich feuchte handinnenflächen jedes
mal wenn ich versuche so schießt von der
exchange auf meine prognose des edel
sorgt im prinzip so lang nicht mehr
anrufen kann und sagen kann was ist denn
bitte main-post rot gehüllt das geld
nicht wirklich und das war natürlich
damals nicht bevor man es hören dass
liebe auch nicht an dieser logik der
dezentralisierung jetzt haben haben sie
gesagt ja wenn ich jetzt in el salvador
in der türkei dann kaufe ich bin dann
bin ich geschützt jetzt ist es ja nun so
wenn man sich den kursverlauf von
bitcoin anschaut die volatilität ist
doch ganz enorm und wenn sie mal zu
hause spaß haben wollen einen tag lang
den kurs zu verfolgen da werden sie
schwankungen sehen die sie sonst fast
nirgendwo sehen das heißt zu sagen dass
das in irgendeiner form eine risikolose
wertanlage wäre das wäre ja nun wirklich
unverantwortlich da sehe ich auch so ich
würde vielen leuten eher abraten davon
aber wenn man freude dann hat sich
hermann geholt da natürlich zu raten
klar warum nicht das ist eine
alternative anlageform oder im prinzip
kriegt man einen blick in die zukunft
auf diese art und weise aber
jetzt jemandem ab das vom fehlen der
digital sich auf kriegsfuß ist das
wirklich lieber nicht machen und ein
mann soll der hat generell keine
investment zählungen geben weil ein
investment ist etwas das man zu sich
selber entscheiden muss nur dann kann
man dahinter stehen denn sie müssen bei
jedem investment nicht nur bei bitkom
ist die gefahr dass sie ihre
investitionen verlieren zwingend gegeben
sonst gäbe es keine rendite rendite ist
die belohnung für das risiko ihr
eingesetztes kapital zu verlieren nun
gibt es völlig richtig volatilere und
weniger volatile anlageform und der
bitcoin ist schon eine ganz ordentliche
achterbahnfahrt aber da haben wir uns
diese achterbahnfahrt mal genauer anwalt
einerseits weil man sagen dass es nach
der bahnfahrt andererseits ist es aber
auch eine seilbahn weil wenn man eine
gerade durchzieht hat es sich in den
letzten sechs jahren verdreißigfacht das
ist nur eine frage der zeitlichen
perspektive und das heißt übersetzt ins
ins investieren ihres anlagehorizont ist
man könnte auch sagen volatilität is
your friend woher soll denn die rendite
kommen wenn nicht aus der volatilität
bei etwas das absolut neu ist seit 13
jahren gibt ich sehe da eine riesen
karriere für sie als anlageberater aber
investitions tipps wollen wir hier nicht
geben wir wollen das ja verstehen und
was ich immer noch nicht genau
verstanden habe ich sehe so viele
vorteile die sie jetzt auch ausgelegt
haben es muss doch etwas daran geben
dass in gewisser weise an sich
problematisch ist sonst würde man sagen
ja warum steht die welt wenn ich auf
bitkom über um das wäre doch dann für
alle besser es gibt drei bis vier
grundsätzliche dieser einen fehler über
die sonne blicken das eine ist wie für
transaktionen pro sekunde verarbeitet
werden können das ist einfach stark
beschränkt einfach wie die technologie
gebaut was ist als zahlungsmittel damit
begrenzt hienheimer nur ein paar
transaktionen pro sekunde weltweit
ausfüllen kann es viel viel weniger dass
kreditkarten heute schon noch
das zweite ist die frage wie lange es
dauert bis die transaktion ausgeführt
ist wenn ich jetzt von einem automaten
stehen getränke aus lassen möchte dann
möchte ich nicht eine stunde warten bis
diese tradition tatsächlich sicher in
der block 10 ist oder ich möchte das
jetzt das geld rein und dann hab ich's
getränke aus aber erwarten sie wissen
dass beide punkte gelöst sind dabei
willkommen durch es bleibt uns diese
beiden punkte sind mit lightning oder
mit seiner zweifel genannten dreht seine
zwecken
übrigens sind sehr bescheiden mit
entwickelt haben
ich habe deswegen damals kein wodka
gekauft aus der preis noch viel weniger
raus auf dieses cover worden war sondern
nur ein paar franken profitieren weil
ich dachte das geht so nicht und dann
haben wir das geholfen zu lösen dann
hätte ich eigentlich hoffen so auf den
punkt habe aber trotzdem nicht unter
dritte punkt und betritt der vierte
punkt ist die energieproblematik die in
vielen bereichen des lebens sprechen wir
starke energie verbraucht und deswegen
darf man nach jeder über sprechen das
ist einfach ein riesiger um die relation
zu nennen die bitcoin mining energie der
bitkom einen energieverbrauch entspricht
derzeit etwa dem energieverbrauch von
den niederlanden oder von der ukraine
0,5 prozent das weltweite energie wasser
schon erheblich klingt und obwohl auch
ist was erheblich klingt es fast 100
prozent für das mining da ist und nicht
für die eigentlichen andere sachen das
könne man sich sagen dass einige kämpfer
vielleicht umstellen oder statt dass man
diese
zugwaggons berechnet mit komplizierten
krypta tricks könnte man auch sagen das
ist unser blog wir hängen reihe um
meinen wagen oder jede von uns darf man
wahrgenommen so ein bisschen vereinfacht
gesagt jetzt kann man sagen ja wer ist
dann jede wehrmacht jetzt damit und so
aber das hat man im prinzip im griff und
aber bitkom wird sich das nicht mehr
ändern bei anderen blogs bei anderen
währungen hat man das eigentlich besser
gelöst und das ist vielleicht das vierte
und letzte bitcoin das bitcoin einfach
sehr schwierig zu reformieren ist das
ist wie die man so will die katholische
kirche unter den religionen und ein
krypteria basisdemokratisch verwaltet
basisdemokratischen wollte aber die
meine sind die die das sagen haben da
wenn man den eindruck durch kriegen
möchte muss man den wählern
anschauen und die meint werden das
meinen nicht wegnehmen dass das klingt
schon im norden so weil das die macht
ist mal haben dass die macht ist und
auch das geld das sie verdienen sie
haben investitionen getätigt möchten
diese investitionen natürlich gewinn
abwerfen sehen und deswegen wird sich
das wahrscheinlich nicht ändern also
es gibt auch im club-tor space und
beatrice bessere unterschiedliche
ansichten und wer bin ich mich mit so
einem eminenten informatiker anzulegen
aber ich würde doch sagen wollen das
bitcoin so schwer
veränderbar ist
nimmt man heutzutage immer sagen ist ein
feature na de bug ist ein vorteil ist
eine tugend ist eine wahre stärke die
anderen crypto währungen die sich wie
finde gewaltig von den 7000 gibt
mittlerweile auf diesem planet und wie
sie von der ganzen strukturen von
konzeptionen total entscheiden von
unterscheiden von bitcoin wir haben
diese schwerfälligkeit nicht aber die
schwerfälligkeit ist die sicherheit von
bitcoin die schwerfälligkeit ist die
verlässlichkeit wir wissen dieses bitkom
protokoll ist nicht änderbar bei evi um
gibt es eine andere kultur währung
jährige die in populären foundation von
der man weiß dass er im größeren
thailands hat die leute die die machen
werden künstliche umsteigen auf proof
auf steak das verbraucht weniger energie
hat aber damit auch nicht mehr die
gleichen das ist gleich hohe maß an
dezentralität
es ist immer so ein trade off zwischen
skalierbarkeit auf der einen seite und
dezentralität auf der anderen wir
bitcoin
basisdemokraten und anarchisten die wir
sind wir glauben absolut an
dezentralität als den höchsten wert aber
wenig und das ist ja sozial doch
interessant herren warten rover richtig
verstanden habe gibt es doch eine eigene
priesterkaste innerhalb dieser kirche
die doch ein bisschen mehr macht hat als
die anderen kann man darüber diskutieren
ob es die männer sind oder nicht er die
not und die notes meinen nicht und haben
andere interessen
übrigens wollen wir vom priester kasten
sprechen das ist ja nun als soziotop als
milieu der bitcoin absolut männlich
dominiert meistens menschen die stark
innerhalb dieser technologie schon
vorkenntnisse haben da kann man sagen da
wird wissen und vielleicht sogar
geschlecht auch zu einem machtfaktor
nämlich zu einem finanziellen nacht
aktor das kennen sie ja vielleicht auch
wahrscheinlich aus ihrem studiengang ist
das denn wirklich immer noch so dass das
ein rein ein vorrangig männlich
dominiertes gebiet ist in
europa oder im westend ja
weltweit ist das nicht so klar dass das
so stark männlich dominiert ist ich
würde sagen das ist jetzt für die
informatik gesprochen fürbitten
gesprochen ist wahrscheinlich noch ein
bisschen schlimmer noch ein bisschen
männliche dominiert
ich weiß nicht was die manager am 17
irgendwelche ideen das kulturbudget ich
bedauere das auch generell ist aber so
dass bei allen finanziellen fragen und
frauen weniger engagiert sind als männer
das dort wo es um reines investieren
geht ist es ja genauso deswegen
würde ich auch sagen es
stimmt bitkom es extrem männlich
dominiert aber was nicht ganz stimmt
wenn wenn sie haben gesagt so leute sie
für technologie informatik interessieren
der bitkom hat einfach diese vielen
aspekte die technologische die spiele
theoretische die ökonomische die
philosophische die metaphysische
wirklich auch die metaphysische und
jeder findet einen anderen zugang und
zwar je nachdem wo er herkommt wenn ich
komme vielleicht eher von meinen
interessen er von der geldtheorie her
das hat mich immer schon fasziniert das
ist mein zug ich aber fest es bringt
nichts sich nur mit geldtheorie zu
befassen sondern ich muss auch so schwer
ist mir fällt mich irgendwie versuchen
kryptographie ein zu denken und diesen
diesen erkenntnisprozess machen alle
bitkom dadurch sie müssen sie sind
konfrontiert mit wissensgebieten in
denen sie sich eigentlich nicht
auskennen und diese sich erst mal so
drauf schaffen müssen das wäre ja
kulturell schön wenn man sagt was immer
ihr von bitcoin haltet die beschäftigung
damit gibt euch gewisser weise einsicht
in den maschinenraum unserer
gesellschaft und zwar unserer
zukünftigen gesellschaft auf jeden fall
das macht die kryptographie verwenden
wir deshalb vielen jahren schon täglich
mit dem internet surfen ist er total
übrig und die leute benutzen das einfach
und interessieren sich nicht dafür
dieses bitcoin problem dass man das geld
doppelte ausgeben kann das hat die leute
wirklich fasziniert würde ich sagen
damals musste ich allen leuten erklären
dass das wesen rauf kommt was wie geht
das überhaupt dass ich habe nicht nur
eine e mail mit geld schicken dann haben
wir es beide wie kann man das
technologisch lösen und das ist etwas
was sehr sichtbar ist für alle und
drogen glaube ich haben sie hat nicht
viele leute damit herr mangold dann in
die cryptic wie ein gelesen weil sie
gedacht haben vielleicht gibt es da was
sehr sportlich wissen erst seit ich
nicht mit dem bitkom beschäftige ist mir
klar warum ich bei meinem e mail
passwort tatsächlich bisschen
raffinierter sein sollte als ich es
bisher war sensibilisierung für aspekte
die so gar nicht auf die jetzt gibt es
noch einen punkt bei bit konnte mir doch
entscheiden scheint die absolute anzahl
von zu existierenden bitcoins ist
begrenzt die wird 21 millionen betragen
die letzte ausschüttung oder generiert
von neuen konflikt im jahr 2000
124 etwa und das ist nun anders als
jedes andere werthaltige material von
dem wir auf dieser welt wissen es ist
eine absolute in ihrer menge detailiert
bestimmbare form von digitaler knappheit
und zumindest das muss man sagen das ist
doch unglaublich geistig anregend sich
vorzustellen dass wir mit digitalen
mitteln etwas wertvolles schaffen kann
dessen gesamtmenge absehbar absolut
begrenzt ist ganz anders als geld und
übrigens auch anders als gold weil
niemand weiß ja letztlich wie für gold
noch gefunden würde als vergleichbare
wertanlage zum beispiel auf einem
anderen planeten der plätze in unserer
reichweite gerät um vielleicht sogar ein
klein bisschen fehlen würde ich sagen so
jetzt finanzpolitik gesprochen weil
diese deflationäre tendenz die man
dadurch kriegt
was bedeutet dass die leute das geld
horten werden oder dass ihr sohn er
heißt dass man sich für die gleiche
summe zukünftig mehr bei mir kaufen kann
man meister der gesamtbetrag ist
begrenzt man weiß wenn ich das halte 100
jahre lang sozusagen einen kinder
weitervererben dann ist es vielleicht
potenziell viel mehrwert in 100 jahren
allerdings nicht aus und wenn das dann
alles so machen verliert so ein bisschen
den grund überhaupt hat das sollte ein
zahlungsmittel seien und nicht etwas
einfach so behält und eine generation
weiter das ist zumindest die klassische
lehre der volkswirtschaftslehre im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert dass es hieß
währungen currencies müssen inflationär
sein weil die leute das geld sonst
horten aber es soll den umlauf kommen
das kann man aber auch anders deuten und
das stimmt völlig was sie sagen der
bitcoin ist gedacht als deflationäres
geldsystem wir hatten schon mal ein
deflationäres geldsystem nämlich dass
wir den goldstandard hatten das
neunzehnte jahrhundert eines der
produktivsten innovativsten jahrhunderte
das unglaubliche technologische
veränderungen gebracht hat wurde auf der
basis eines tendenziell deflationären
goldstandards umgesetzt kurz der
goldstandard zeichnet sich dadurch aus
dass die währung in dieser welt
zumindest die großen an die menge des
goldes gebunden ist die die jeweiligen
volkswirtschaften halten das heißt in
innen zwar mit einem geldschein zur bank
gehen und dafür gold einlösen als
grundidee
würde sagen dieses eben auch viel
stärker deflationäre regiment einer
goldbindung hat das neunzehnte
jahrhundert nicht daran gehindert ein
extrem produktives jahrhundert gewesen
zu sein man könnte auch sagen heute ist
geld billig ist es eigentlich ein
vorteil weil es macht investoren dumm
billiges geld wird einfach rauskommen
wir sehen dass die wall street hat sich
das billige geld von der zentralbank und
kauft und kauft meinetwegen davon bleibt
es leid es irgendwelche großen
unternehmen die davon ihre eigenen
aktien zurückkaufen und dadurch haben
wir diese aufblähung des gesamten
finanzierten sektors den wir nicht
wollen für genau jene die kein geld
haben der ja auch hohe ungleichheiten
sind nur perpetuiert und leicht steigen
gebracht hat und deswegen ist die die
die vorstellung die bitcoin mit einem
deflationären geld regiment verbinden
auch eine von höhere gerechtigkeit und
gleichheit das ist ein ganz
interessanter punkt weil in der
öffentlichkeit wird es oft falsch
gesehen in der öffentlichkeit die sich
noch kaum damit auseinandergesetzt hat
werden wird koller immer gerne in
verbindung gebracht zu zockern den es
nur darum geht den nächsten lambo den
nächsten lamborghini zu fuß mit der
goldkette die jungs wäre wohl meine
erfahrung
in diesem für mich waren sich bereichern
den letzten jahren mit so vielen jungen
leuten die sich für die tollen
begeistern ist komplett was anderes das
ist ein gesellschaftspolitisch hoch
bewusst seine bilder natürlich hoch
bewusste
jugendbewegung die genau an diesen
knackpunkten unseres systems ansätze
sagt inflation ist auch eine
umverteilung von unten nach oben
deswegen wollen wir kein inflationäres
regiment mehr und so weiter das heißt
gerechtigkeitsfragen natürlich im geist
der freiheit gar keine frage und die
selbstverantwortung im geist der
freiheit und selbstverantwortung sind
die gerechtigkeitsfragen ganz ganz
obenan geschrieben in dieser welt
gestoßen glaube ich hier auf etwas
interessant dass man könnte nämlich
sagen bitcoin ist eine art intakter
utopie stadt diskurs das geld zu
verändern wie sie die welt zu verändern
und dies gibt es ja diesen schönen song
von john lennon imagine stellen wir uns
mal eine welt vor in der bitcoin die
grund währung dieses planeten wäre
erwarten hofer auf dieser welt gebe es
keine zentralbanken mehr keine banken
mehr und keine wertschöpfung mehr aus
dem nichts das heißt keine inflation im
uns bekannten sinne richtig
zentralbanken ja die kerbs nicht mehr
spielzeugen publikum spontan ist nicht
so klar ich würde vermuten die gibt es
trotzdem noch zum beispiel jemand den
raum rufen kann wenn man das passwort
vergessen hat
ich glaube die größere umwelt zunächst
wirklich er dann auf der gefäße
gesellschaftspolitischen nicht monetären
seite sondern auf der was bedeutet
demokratie was bedeutet es eine stimme
abzugeben
all das kann man auch in einem blog 10
speichen und ich glaube dass ich fast
einen größeren
größere möglichkeit also das heißt wenn
jetzt volksabstimmungen der schweiz ist
dann wird das demnächst vielleicht in 20
jahren an block chain abstimmung sein
und kinder werden ihre eltern fragen wie
man es vom seiten jeder hingegangen so
ich würde hoffen dass es in diese
richtung geht vielleicht ist es nicht
das hauptproblem der schweiz habe man
kann sich schon fragen oder man möchte
wissen aus in einer demokratie möchte
man wissen wurde meine stimme gezählt
wohl nicht stimmen gezählt die dauer von
leuten die gar nicht existieren und die
burg ziehen würde uns die möglichkeiten
geben das zu prüfen es ist so dass in
der schweiz bei wahlen zum teil ein
viertel der stimmzettel ungültig ist und
ich zum beispiel frage mich jemand aus
meiner ungültig wir haben viele
möglichkeiten das rauchen zu streichen
oder namen dazu zufügen also ich vermute
dass viele leute da kleine fehler machen
und dann wird die ganze prozedur günstig
in einem blog 10.000 lösen könnten leute
überprüfen der besteht tatsächlich
gezählt wurde auf mich ganz einfach hier
und weiß aber das hat ja auch diese
rückführbarkeit und diese sicherheit der
adressierung hat ja auch dunkler seit
man könnte sagen der diktator weiß was
ich gewählt habe
das ist ja die dunkle seite dieser block
ventil technologie sie ist einerseits
ein befreien von emanzipation schub aber
wenn ich es richtig sehe in zentralen
händen die vielleicht nicht so
freiheitliche ideen haben bedeutet dass
alle transaktionen die ich je getätigt
habe rückkehrer sind das also jemand
alles über mich weiß man könnte sich ja
leicht ausrichten da geht es nicht um
eine freiheitliche utopie das ist eine
art digitaler stalin ist muss der sich
damit etablieren lässt ja das ist ganz
neu war ein anderer das ist sehr wichtig
dass diese pseudo anonymität wie wir
gehört haben dass die funktioniert oder
wenn man dann nachprüfen kann wer was
gemacht wenn man dann anschaut die
zentralbank steht auch in werbung
bekommen sollen und dann das komplett
kontrolliert dann ist natürlich dann
geht es genau eine baustelle sowie in
china jetzt also crypto währung ist
nicht gleich crypto währungs und sobald
sie von einem staat zentral verwaltet
ist nimmt sie ganz ganz andere
charaktere genau deswegen völlig absurd
geradezu beim digitalen yuan an dem die
chinesische regierung arbeitet von
teschen technisch mag mögen die die
blogs schreiben benutzen das ist keine
dezentrale bloggt er in eine
zentralisierte blogs können wir gleich
beim alten system bereiten das ist das
haar das hatten wir aber das aber für
den diktator wie sie es entworfen haben
ist in der dezentralen blog china keine
position vorgesehen jetzt könnte man ja
sagen wir haben gerade so einen kampf
wir haben eigentlich den kampf zweier
systeme wie gesellschaft zu gestalten
wäre ein freiheitlicher und dann eher
autokratischer ist bitcoin so eine art
positions- stelle an dem sich dieser
kampf gerade austrägt und vielleicht
sogar entscheidet ich glaube unbedingt
und ich glaube es ist auch kein zufall
dass china im letzten jahr ich glaube
meine juni bis dahin war china das
zentrum der das bitcoin mining und dann
hat china die männer des landes
verwiesen was das netzwerk als ganzes in
bewunderung würdiger weise verkraftet
hat weil es sich jederzeit neu
organisieren kann dass man auch
dezentralität es gibt kein single point
of failure
man kann nicht einen kopf abschlagen und
glauben das ganze system legen sondern
das organisiert sich sofort über den
globus verteilt woanders neu aber dass
china die bitcoin meine verband hat
drückt auch auf das für ein
autokratisches system
der bitkom eine bedrohung ist und
deswegen sollten länder die im geiste
der freiheit leben ihn annehmen denn er
ist ein medium der freiheit in meiner
sicht eher ist schon auch natürlich für
unsere
überlieferten institutionen eine
herausforderung die große analogie der
große vergleich habe ich glaube nicht
dass er zu groß gewählt das ist haben
eine parallele bewegung was im 16 15 und
16 jahrhundert die trennung von staat
und kirche war werden wir das ist meine
prognose jetzt als die trennung von
staat und geld an eine neue reformation
ja ja das eine neue reformation das ist
nicht die abschaffung des staates ich
bin überhaupt kein anarchist in diesem
sinne ich glaube an ordnungsstrukturen
die wir alle quasi durch unsere
mitarbeiter legitimieren darum geht es
mir nicht aber es ist nicht zwingend
dass in einem freiheitlichen staatswesen
es diesen einen punkt gibt wo gewissen
zentral
über das geld verfügt werden kann das
geld friedrich von hayek einer der
großen vordenker der österreichischen
schule der ökonomik der hatte selber
schon die idee den 70er jahren
entwickelt zu sagen wir brauchen eine
währung wir brauchen ein freies privates
geld das zueinander in einem wettbewerb
und damals gab es aber eigentlich gab es
hat noch keine technologischen
möglichkeiten das umzusetzen diese welt
treten jetzt ein 2009 kam mit einem acht
seiten papier
dieses geld in die welt es wird wollen
uns noch eine weile begleiten spinnen
wir mal 15 jahre 25 jahre voraus
erwarten hofer wenn sie sagen das ist
eine der größten technischen
revolutionen der letzten 100 jahre woran
werden sie sich und das ist meine letzte
frage an sie beide hauptsächlich sehen
und wird es zb dann wie sie wirklich
glauben könnten in 30 jahren keine
zentralbanken mit dieser macht mehr
geben
es ist dann schwierig gesetzten
also zentralbanken werden sie sich mit
händen und füßen dagegen wehren dass sie
unwichtig werden aber ich glaube was wir
sehen hier ist ein system das diese
frage der zentralisierung unter
dezentralisierung aufs tapet gebracht
wir können jetzt verstehen um was es da
geht an einem sehr konkreten beispiel
und ich persönlich finde es sehr
spannend diese frage da hin zu spielen
was muss eigentlich sind rau sein und
was musste nicht zentral sein was könnte
sehr viel effizientere das sicher sein
und nicht zentral ist und ich glaube
schon dass es in 30 jahren noch da sein
wird aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht ob es
viel stärker ist komplett das monopol
auf das geldsystem oder so wie heute da
vielleicht noch weniger nicht
der philosoph und literaturkritiker eine
ganz kurze utopie in fünf sätzen bitcoin
welt wie sie singen die die utopie der
bitcoin lautet immer des stärkstes
härteste geld setzt sich durch so war
das auch früher eine konkurrenz zwischen
gold und silber und wenn das so ist dann
wird sich der bitkom durchsetzen dann
kämen wir in den zustand der ipad mit
conny station also dort wo weltweit
sowohl als store of value als wert
aufbewahrung wie als currency also um
damit zu bezahlen wie auch als
recheneinheit im bitcoin gedacht im
bitkom gedacht wird er würde sich dann
durchsetzen das ist aber ich bin kein
utopischer ich hab bin eigentlich ein
liberaler skeptiker das heißt ich glaube
an pluralismus und auch an wettbewerb
ich bin absolut überzeugt dass der
bitkom nicht mehr wegzudenken ist und
dass er immer größer wird und eine
größere rolle spielen wird es wird aber
könnte ich mir vorstellen durchaus
andere konkurrierende systeme geben und
konkurrierende systeme ist etwas was ich
sehr schätze dass im prinzip von checks
and balances dann kann jeder zeigen wie
leistungsstark gewissermaßen seinen
treuen ist und der bessere kann sich
dann für jede die jeweilige
funktionalität durchsetzen also wir sind
ja alle und das wissen wir doch narren
der zukunft was sie bringen wird wissen
wir nicht aber vielleicht können wir 20
jahren nochmal dieses gespräch anschauen
und sehen wie wir gelegen haben auf
jeden fall vielen dank für ihre
einsichten und für ihre schöne bitcoin
energie
nächste woche wiederholen wir dann ein
gespräch mit meiner kollegin barbara
bleisch zum thema lust mit dem
philosophen konrad paul liessmann ich
jetzt gleich folgt das abstimmungs
studio bleiben sie also dran für andere
wertvoll und denken sie weiter
[Musik]